MISLEADING YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SIT TIGHT.
IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT VERY
IMPORTANT NEWS BREAKING OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ HAS A LOT OF EXPLAINING
AFTER 18 MONTHS OF WORK, HIS
REPORT WAS RELEASED LAST
THURSDAY AND IT SHOWS THE HUGE,
MASSIVE MISSTEPS, CORRUPTION,
MISTAKES SURROUNDING THE FBI AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DURING
THE SO-CALLED CLINTON
INVESTIGATION, INCLUDING EXAMPLE
AFTER EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
FIX WAS IN FROM THE GET-GO TO
HELP HILLARY CLINTON AND
LITERALLY DESTROY THEN CANDIDATE
DONALD TRUMP.
HOWEVER, THE IG DID NOT MAKE
PROSECUTORIAL CONCLUSIONS ABOUT
THE OBVIOUS FELONIES THAT
HILLARY COMMITTED AND WAS
TOTALLY AND UNJUSTLY EXONERATED
FROM.
THE FACTS ARE ACTUALLY, AS WE'VE
BEEN TELLING YOU FROM THE
GET-GO, AND THEY ARE
IRREFUTABLE.
MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED,
TOP-SECRET INFORMATION ON A
PRIVATE SERVER.
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE, DELETING
33,000 SUBPOENAED EMAILS, ACID
WASHING THE HARD DRIVE WITH
BLEACH BIT AND HAVING AIDS
DESTROY EVIDENCE, DEVICES WITH A
HAMMER.
AND REMOVING SIM CARDS.
ANY OTHER AMERICAN, AND A VIEW
OUT THERE WOULD'VE BEEN LOCKED
UP, THROWN IN PRISON FOR EXACTLY
WHAT HILLARY CLINTON DID.
STILL, THE IG REPORT DO NOT
FAULT THE FES DECISION TO CLEAR
CLINTON OF ALL CHARGES.
WHAT THEY REALLY DECIDED IS "NOT
TO SECOND-GUESS THE CONCLUSIONS
WHILE THEY IN FACT PRESENTED
WHAT IS NOW A MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE PROVING THE GUILT.
SADLY THE SWAMP PROTECTS THE
SWAMP.
IT'S NOW CLEAR IF HILLARY RODHAM
CLINTON HAD A REAL
INVESTIGATION, SHE WOULD HAVE
BEEN INDICTED.
POLITICS OF THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
THE FBI SADLY PREVENTED ALL OF
THAT.
LET'S BREAK THINGS DOWN IN THESE
FINDINGS.
SEE IF ANY REASONABLE PERSON
WOULD EVER MAKE THE CONCLUSION
THAT POLITICAL BUYERS DID NOT
PLAY A MAJOR ROLE INSIDE THE
FBI.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS TEXT.
AUGUST 8, 2016, HIGH-RANKING FBI
ATTORNEY LISA PAGE AND HER
COLLEAGUE, BOYFRIEND PETER
STRZOK WHO WAS THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR IN THE CLINTON
CASE.
LISA PAGE WRITES "TRUMP IS NOT
EVER GOING TO BECOME PRESIDENT,
RIGHT?"
STRZOK REPLIES NO, NO, HE'S NOT.
WE WILL STOP IT.
THEN PAGE CALLS TRUMP AND EXITED
THEN PAGE CALLS TRUMP AND EXITE
EXITED.
IDIOT, MENACE, LOATHSOME HUMAN
BEING.
THIS IS FROM THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR AND THE LEAD FBI
ATTORNEY.
THE BIAS DIDN'T STOP WITH THEM.
THE MESSAGE FROM YET ANOTHER
HIGH-RANKING AGENT ON THE CASE.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE POOR TO
MIDDLE-CLASS, UNEDUCATED, LAZY
POS THINK HE WILL MAGICALLY
GRANT THEM JOBS FOR DOING
NOTHING.
ONE AGENT INTERVIEWED
HILLARY CLINTON CALLED HER THE
PRESIDENT.
IN A MESSAGE TO A COLLEAGUE,
SAID "TRUMP CAN'T WIN."
OCTOBER 28, 2016, SHORTLY AFTER
COMEY ANNOUNCED HE WOULD BE
REOPENING THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION, ANOTHER UNNAMED
FBI ATTORNEY SENT AN INSTANT
MESSAGE TO A FELLOW FBI EMPLOYEE
AND THAT READ "I AM CLINGING TO
SMALL POCKETS OF HAPPINESS IN
THE DARK TIMES OF THE REPUBLIC'S
DESTRUCTION."
FOLLOWING TRUMP'S ELECTION
VICTORY, THAT SAME FBI ATTORNEY
SENT AN INSTANT MESSAGE AND THAT
READ "I AM NUMB."
FELLOW EMPLOYEE RESPONDING "I
CAN'T STOP CRYING."
GET THIS, ACCORDING TO THE IG
REPORT, "AGENTS INVOLVED IN THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION INVESTIGATED
WERE INSTRUCTED TO TAKE NO OVERT
INVESTIGATIVE STEPS PRIOR TO THE
INVESTIGATIVE STEPS PRIOR TO THT
INVESTIGATIVE STEPS PRIOR TO THO
INVESTIGATIVE STEPS PRIOR TO TH.
INVESTIGATIVE STEPS PRIOR TO TH"
WOULD YOU GET THAT TREATMENT?
THIS OF COURSE IS THE REPORT
FOUND THAT THE FBI WAS ACTUALLY
INTIMIDATED BY CLINTON'S
HIGH-RANKING LEGAL TEAM.
THE REPORT ALSO FOUND THAT
HIGH-RANKING DOJ OFFICIALS TRIED
TO GET A JOB FOR HIS SON IN THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
I'LL WHILE SHARING, LINKING
CASE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ONGOING SERVER INVESTIGATION THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN
JOHN PODESTA.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THERE IS SO
MUCH MORE.
LISTEN TO WHAT SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM LAID OUT AT TODAY'S
HEARING.
HE WAS ON FIRE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS WAS AN EMAIL SENT IN
FEBRUARY 2016.
FROM PAGE TO McCABE.
"HEY, USUALLY ALREADY CONSIDERED
THIS.
BUT IN MY VIEW, OUR BEST REASON
TO HOLD THE LINE AT 2 AND 2, TWO
AGENTS INTO PROSECUTORS ISSUE
MIGHT BE OUR NEXT PRESIDENT."
HOW DID YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT IT
AND WE LAID IT OUT WHY.
>> LET'S KEEP TALKING ABOUT THIS
INTERVIEW.
ONE OF THE FBI AGENTS IN THE
INTERVIEW SAID ON ELECTION DAY
TO ANOTHER FBI AGENT, YOU SHOULD
KNOW THAT I AM WITH HER.
"HER," WAS CLINTON, RIGHT?
>> >> CORRECT.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> VERY CONCERNED.
>> EVENTUALLY VERY CONCERNED
SEEMS TO BE ENOUGH ALREADY.
I'M GLAD YOU FOUND WHAT YOU
FOUND, MR. HORWITZ.
I'M NOT BUYING THAT THE CLINTON
EMAIL AND PRESTIGE WAS ON THE UP
AND UP.
>> Sean: I AM NOT BUYING IT
EITHER.
YOU STILL THINK POLITICAL BIAS
DIDN'T PLAY A ROLE IN THE FBI'S
DECISIONS?
AT THE CENTER OF ALL THIS IS FBI
TRUMP-HATING AGENT PETER STRZOK.
HE IS BEING SUBPOENAED BY THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN
ORDER TO BETTER DETERMINE WHY
THE FBI AND THE DOJ WITHHELD
MANY OF HIS ANTI-TRUMP TEXT.
WE STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN THEM
ALL.
REMEMBER, HE WAS THE LEAD FBI
AGENT IN THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
HE IS THE ONE WHO VOWED TO STOP
A TRUMP PRESIDENCY IN A TEXT
WITH HIS GIRLFRIEND, LISA PAGE.
ACCORDING TO THE IG REPORT, PAGE
WAS A HIGH-RANKING FBI ATTORNEY
WHO WAS USED BY ANDREW MCCABE.
YEAH, THAT ANDREW MCCABE.
OF COURSE THEY BYPASS THE FBI'S
CHAIN OF COMMAND AND HE GOT TO
MANAGER THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
NEXT WE KNEW PETER STRZOK,
ANDREW WEISSMANN, THOSE NAMES
SOUND FAMILIAR?
THOSE ANTI-TRUMP DEMOCRATIC
DONORS HAD THE SAME PEOPLE TO
FINISH THE EXONERATION OF
HILLARY AND PUT THE FIX IN AND
TAPPED BY ROBERT MUELLER FOR HIS
TRUMP-RUSSIA WITCH HUNT.
MANY OF THOSE SAME AGENTS THAT
CLEARED HILLARY, THEY WERE THEN
IMMEDIATELY APPOINTED TO
INVESTIGATE TRUMP.
THE VERY AGENTS HATRED ABOUT
TRUMP, VOWING TO STOP
HIS PRESIDENCY, MOCKING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, THE SAME PEOPLE
TAPPED TO INVESTIGATE TRUMP.
QUESTION BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, WHICH MEANS
THE ENTIRE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
FROM THE GET-GO WAS AS CORRUPT
AS THE HILLARY COVER-UP, AND IT
WAS THE CASE FROM DAY ONE.
THAT'S THE VERY DEFINITION
ITSELF RIGHT THERE OF WHAT I'VE
BEEN SAYING.
A TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
NO EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW
OR EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS
OR EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAW
LAWS.
IF TRUE JUSTICE HAD PREVAILED,
IF HILLARY CLINTON GOT INDICTED,
AS SHE SHOULD HAVE IN THE FALL
OF 2016, THE ELECTORAL PROCESS
WOULD'VE BEEN TURNED ON ITS
HEAD.
THE DEEP STATES OF CHOICE FOR
PRESIDENT WOULD BE OUT OF THE
RACE.
TRUMP WOULD ACTUALLY BE THE
RESIDENT WITHOUT ANY OF THIS
MUELLER GARBAGE THAT HE'S HAD TO
DEAL WITH ALMOST HIS ENTIRE
PRESIDENCY.
THAT'S WHY HILLARY CLINTON, SHE
GOT THE WHITE GLOVE TREATMENT BY
THESE INVESTIGATORS, OPENLY
ROOTING FOR HER TO WIN THE
ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, EVERYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM, THEY GOT
THE SLEDGEHAMMER.
THROWN DOWN BY THE VERY SAME
PEOPLE THAT GAVE HILLARY A PASS.
TONIGHT WE ARE ALSO LEARNING
JAMES COMEY IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
REMEMBER, HE INTENTIONALLY
LEAKED HIS PERSONAL NOTES ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS HE HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S ILLEGAL.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
IN ORDER TO SET THE BALL ROLLING
FOR THE ANTI-TRUMP SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
HIS BUDDY, ROBERT MUELLER, TO
BEGIN HIS INVESTIGATION OR
WITCH HUNT.
THE IG ALSO FOUND IS FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY WAS INSUBORDINATE
AND TOTALLY MISHANDLED THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
LEGAL SCHOLAR JONATHAN TURLEY, A
DEMOCRAT, IS NOW SAYING THESE
FINDINGS IN THE IG REPORT
EXONERATE TRUMP FROM ANY
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CHARGES
WHICH MEANS THEY SHOULD ALL END
AND END NOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO ME, OBSTRUCTION CLAIM
INVOLVING COMEY WAS ALWAYS
DIFFICULT BUT AFTER THE IG, IT'S
BECOME VIRTUALLY INCOME
PRINCIPAL BECAUSE THE IG SAID
THAT COMEY WAS INSUBORDINATE,
THAT HE DEVIATED FROM POLICIES.
HE VIOLATED FBI POLICIES.
ALL THOSE ARE A GOOD REASON TO
FIRE JAMES COMEY.
SO THE PROBLEM THAT'S GOING TO
COME UP FOR THE CRITICS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THAT THIS DOG
JUST WON'T HUNT WHEN YOU'VE GOT
BOTH THE IG AND THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYING HE
DESERVED TO BE FIRED.
YOU CAN'T ASSUME EVERYTHING
AGAINST HIM.
THERE IS ANOTHER INTERESTING
ASPECT HERE.
IF MUELLER WAS REALLY GOING
AFTER OBSTRUCTION BASED ON COMEY
AFTER OBSTRUCTION BASED ON COME
COMEY, THEN ROSENSTEIN WOULD
HAVE TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
ROSENSTEIN SAID THAT IF MUELLER
TOLD HIM HE WAS A WITNESS, HE
WOULD REMOVE HIMSELF.
HE HASN'T DONE THAT WHICH MAKES
ME THINK ONE OF TWO THINGS.
EITHER MUELLER IS IGNORING
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST OR HE'S
NOT SERIOUSLY PURSUING THAT
ANGLE.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI CALLING
FOR AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATORS, SOMETHING WE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING FOR A LONG TIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> 1 OF 5 INDIVIDUALS OUTLINED
IN THE IG REPORT AS POTENTIALLY
FACING DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
ARE YOU CALLING FOR SOMETHING
SHARPER THAN THAT?
>> YOU ARE DARN RIGHT.
DISCIPLINARY ACTION ON THESE
MAKING COMMENTS LIKE THAT?
NOT PART OF THE PROBE?
HE STARTED IT.
HE WAS WITH IT FOR ITS FIRST
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
MUELLER KEPT HIM ON.
HOW MUCH DID HE INFECT THE PROBE
WITH HIS OWN VERY, VERY EXTREME
POSITIONS?
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I SURE WANT TO FIND OUT
BEFORE I GO FORWARD.
I MEAN, THIS IS A CASE WHERE
IT'S CRYING OUT FOR SOMEONE TO
INVESTIGATE THE INVESTIGATORS.
>> Sean: ABSOLUTELY.
EVEN DEEP STATES I COULD AFFIANT
TURN CNN FAKE NEWS PUNDIT JIM
CLAPPER, HE'S READY FOR MUELLER
TO WRAP THIS UP.
HE LIKELY KNOWS HE AND BRENDAN
WILL EVENTUALLY BE EXPOSED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THE OVERARCHING POINT
HERE IS THIS WHOLE ISSUE HAS GOT
TO COME TO A RESOLUTION.
AT SOME POINT.
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER AND HIS
TEAM I HOPE WILL WRAP UP THE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER WHETHER ORN
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER WHETHER ORT
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER WHETHER ORE
WAS COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THIS IS A CLOUD THAT'S HANGING
OVER THE COUNTRY AND CERTAINLY
HANGING OVER THIS PRESIDENCY.
AND I DO HOPE THAT HAPPENS.
>> Sean: CHANGE OF HEART?
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
ON MUELLER IN THE IG REPORT IN
JUST A MOMENT.
FIRST LET'S TURN TO A STORY
THAT'S CAUSING A FIVE-ALARM FIRE
IN THE HALLS OF THE MAINSTREAM
DESTROY-TRUMP MEDIA SURROUNDING
REPORTS THAT THE CHILDREN OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS
UPON ENTERING THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
LOOK, LET'S START AND BE CLEAR.
NOBODY, NOBODY WANTS CHILDREN
WHO ARE SAFELY IN THE CUSTODY OF
THEIR PARENTS SEPARATED.
NOBODY WANTS THAT.
BUT TRUTH MATTERS, AND FACTS
MATTER.
EARLIER TODAY, DHS SECRETARY
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN RESPONDED TO
THESE CLAIMS, SHE SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT WITH IMPORTANT
INFORMATION THAT THE MEDIA IS
ALL TOO HAPPY AS USUAL TO
IGNORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET'S JUST START WITH A FEW
NUMBERS AND FACTS.
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS, WE'VE
SEEN ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER EXCEED 50,000
PEOPLE EACH MONTH.
MULTIPLES OVER EACH MONTH LAST
YEAR.
SINCE THIS TIME LAST YEAR,
THERE'S BEEN A 325% INCREASE IN
UNACCOMPANIED ALIEN CHILDREN AND
A 435% INCREASE IN FAMILY UNITS
ENTERING THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS, THERE'S
BEEN A 1700% INCREASE IN ASYLUM
CLAIMS.
RESULTING IN AN ASYLUM BACKLOG
IN OUR COUNTRY OF 600,000 CASES.
SINCE 2013, THE UNITED STATES
HAS ADMITTED MORE THAN HALF A
MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT MINERS
AND FAMILY UNITS FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA, MOST OF WHOM
TODAY ARE AT LARGE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AT THE SAME TIME, LARGE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATION SUCH AS MS-13 HAVE
VIOLATED OUR BORDERS AND GAINED
A DEADLY FOOTHOLD WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS ENTIRE CRISIS, JUST TO BE
CLEAR, IS NOT NEW.
IT'S BEEN OCCURRING AND EXPANDED
OVER MANY DECADES.
BUT CURRENTLY IT'S THE EXCLUSIVE
PRODUCT OF LOOPHOLES IN OUR
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW THAT
PREVENT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
MINORS AND FAMILY MEMBERS FROM
BEING DETAINED AND REMOVED THEIR
HOME COUNTRY.
>> Sean: SECRETARY NIELSEN
WENT ON TO EXPLAIN WHY IN SOME
RARE CASES THE CHILDREN OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE SEPARATED
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> DHS DOES HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROTECT MINORS, AND IN THAT
CASE AS WELL WE WILL ONLY SUPPER
THE FAMILY IF WE CANNOT
DETERMINE THERE IS A FAMILIAR
RELATIONSHIP, IF THE CHILD MAY
BE AT RISK WITH THE PARENT OR
LEGAL GUARDIAN, OR IF THE PARENT
OR LEGAL GUARDIAN IS REFERRED
FOR PROSECUTION.
>> Sean: NIELSEN ALSO MADE AN
IMPORTANT COMPARISON TO HOW THE
GOVERNMENT TREATS OUR OWN
CITIZENS.
OH, IMPORTANT.
TAKE A WATCH.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR.
IF AN AMERICAN WERE TO COMMIT A
CRIME ANYWHERE IN THE
UNITED STATES COME IN THEY WOULD
GO TO JAIL AND THEY WOULD BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILY.
THIS IS NOT A CONTROVERSIAL
IDEA.
>> Sean: FINALLY, SECRETARY
NIELSEN REMINDED EVERYONE IN THE
MEDIA THAT THIS IS NOTHING NEW
AND TOOK PLACE IN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS.
YEAH, FACTS MATTER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
BUSH AND ADMINISTRATION ALL
SEPARATED FAMILIES -- THEY
ABSOLUTELY DID.
THEIR RATE WAS LESS THAN OURS
BUT THEY ABSOLUTELY DID DO THIS.
THIS IS NOT NEW.
>> Reporter: MINORS THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
>> THEY SEPARATED FAMILIES.
>> Sean: AN IMPORTANT POINT.
REMEMBERING THE PHOTO SHOWING
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN IN CAGES.
SOME OF THE MEDIA FIRST
ATTRIBUTE OF THAT PICTURE TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BUT IT
ACTUALLY OCCURRED OF COURSE
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IN FACT, THE OBAMA IMAGINATION,
NOT TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT STARTED A
POLICY OF ACTUALLY DETAINING
MINORS FOR MONTHS.
BUT THE MEDIA DIDN'T REPORT,
BARELY ONTO.
IN FACT, ONE DEMOCRAT ACTUALLY
DID ADMIT THAT OBAMA WAS ABLE TO
SOMEHOW KEEP HIS ACTIONS AT THE
BORDER VERY QUIET.
WONDER WHY.
>> UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THERE WAS,
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTING,
A SURGING NUMBER OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS BEING
APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER IN
2014.
THERE WERE NEARLY 70,000,
ACCORDING TO THE POST REPORTING.
>> IN MANY WAYS, I THINK -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IMAGE YOU ARE
USING.
I RELEASED SOME OF THOSE PHOTOS
BECAUSE IT WAS KEPT VERY QUIET
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WERE LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE COMING IN.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS
TRYING TO KEEP THIS QUIET.
>> Sean: OF COURSE NO AID
OUTRAGE FOR THE MEDIA OVER OBAMA
BUT WITHDRAWN, IT'S IT'S A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT STORY.
THERE IS ANOTHER FACTOR.
THEY WANT A DISTRACTION FROM ALL
THE LIES THEY HAVE BEEN PEDDLING
TO YOU FOR THE LAST 18 MONTHS.
AS I SAID EARLIER, NO ONE LIKES
THE IDEA OF SEPARATING ANY CHILD
FROM ANY PARENT.
BUT THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN IN THE
HANDS OF CONGRESS, AND RIGHT NOW
THE WHOLE ISSUE CAN BE FIXED.
EVERY LAW CAN BE CHANGED, AND IF
THEY DID THEIR JOB, IT WOULD
HAPPEN.
IT IS THE LAW.
DEMOCRATS OF COURSE PREFER TO
THEY WANT TO WIN IN 2018.
THEY WANT THEIR POWER BACK.
THOSE ON THE LEFT ONLY WANT OPEN
BORDERS WHICH MEANS THIS ISSUE
PROBABLY IS NOT GOING AWAY.
THEY NEED TO COME TO THE TABLE,
AGREE TO A SERIOUS IMMIGRATION
REFORM, INCLUDING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE WALL.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE PRESIDENT